hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that
was suggested to me by a lot of you as
soon as it ended it basically ended a
few moments ago it was played on
chessbase india's channel under
checkmate covet stream uh where
vishwanathan anand is uh holding uh well
held the simultaneous exhibition against
some of india's uh
uh celebrities uh and in this game he
faced nikol kamath
he's india's youngest billionaire uh who
is a chess player himself but
he did not play chess for a very long
time last time he played chess was when
he was 12 and he
was uh born in 1987 so he's 34 years old
now
and well he's been out of out of chess
for a very long time so i didn't know
what to expect from this game
but was i surprised and uh
it it not only features a really weird
opening sequence it's
one of the rarest moves played in chess
ever i don't think we've ever seen a
game on this channel that featured such
a move you'll you'll see what i'm
talking about
uh so yeah let's just enjoy the game and
for those of you who don't know who this
gentleman is uh you you can google him
but basically
uh he uh he is the founder of azerotha
yeah so it's uh india's largest stock
brokerage company
and well he is obviously very successful
in it since he's india's youngest
billionaire
but that means nothing if you can't play
chess so let's see
how he does against the former world
champion vishwanathan island
so anand has the white pieces as one uh
most often does
when he holds the simultaneous
exhibition and he opens uh with
knight to f3 and also thank you to uh
ketan agrawal for sending me
uh not only the suggestion i received
the suggestion many times but also this
very nice photo of
nikola kamath and some some uh
background on him so here uh vishu opens
with knight to f3 he opens with the
retti opening
and like i said the weirdest opening uh
well
maybe not the weirdest he plays e5 this
is called the ross gambit i have no idea
why
um if any of you guys know do share in
the comments section so we can all enjoy
it but i was
unsuccessful in in locating this
information and it's a really weird move
like there are other weird moves you can
play like
the a you can play like h6 a6 you can
play
a a5 you can play h5 but all of those
moves kind of
make sense e5 is giving up a pawn
you will gain some development for it
but it's so
uh it's it's incredible that um such a
move can can even be played and it's
really remarkable that he plays that
against
none other than former world champion
vishwanathan so here
knight captures an e5 uh onan says thank
you for the pawn
we have d6 chasing the knight back
knight to f3 and now
knight to c6 so already you can see that
black is up in development
but by very little and he's already down
one pawn and
there is one game in the database that
reached this position where g3 was
played but here
uh we have d4 by on and end it is now
already as of move four
uh that we have a completely new game uh
so let's see how the game continues
knight to f6
just nicely continuing development and
now d5 grabbing more space in the center
hoping for a knight to e5 then uh well
you can just continue development or you
can even trade further so here
knight the e5 and knight the c3
uh anand is not uh worried about knight
captures here even though you can double
up pawns
uh it's not a problem you will simply uh
well develop your bishop faster castle
and you will have a safe king while also
being up upon
so here after knight to c3 we have
bishop to e7
uh and e4 now so cementing his uh
advantage here on d5
we have castles and now comes bishop to
e2 so as you can see
uh white caught up in development uh and
the black uh doesn't have all that much
to show for he has a nice knight on e5
but that's only there until ananda
decides otherwise so here he plays c6
it's a very principled move uh as on the
ground more space in the center he may
be
uh overextended a little bit it's uh
it's a nice idea to undermine the center
so here on castles and now c captures on
the e5 we have e captures on the e5 and
now just
e a6 uh here uh
comet wants to play b5 maybe if you can
get to the the light square bishop he
has to develop his queen side somehow
we have rook to e1 not really worried
about bishop to g4
so maybe h3 would be a useless move you
already have a bishop on e2 there's
really no point
and b5 now so grabbing more space here
at some point you might
be interested in this lodging this
knight would be four so a3 on
prevents this and now h6 so just um
preventing the development of white's
pieces on g5
uh i don't know if i mentioned this but
this is a simultaneous exhibition so
anand is
playing against multiple people here uh
can't remember if i've mentioned that
but yeah uh here we have
knight to d4 you could continue by just
developing let's say bishop to f4
and goes knight to d4 he wants to bring
this knight to c6 and then you either
have a monster knight on c6 or
black might trade and then you will have
a very nice pass pawn on c6 so having a
nice pass pawn on c6 being up upon
it's pretty much a winning winning game
so here bishop 37 adding another
defender to this
um c6 square and now bishop to
f4 so if if on and once he can simply
eliminate one of the defenders and then
bring the knight to c6
so rook the c8 adding another defender
to the c6 square and now
bishop to f3 again anand says okay uh
you will uh
you will move this knight at some point
and i will have my knight on c6
so here we have queen to b6 and this is
just a
well it's a it's a very impressive move
because the e5
square is attacked twice so uh can anand
just
grab another pawn here and the answer is
yes for example bishop captures
the captures and now he could play rook
captures on e5 but maybe grabbing the
second pawn
will be a bit too risky because here uh
although
like i said white is up two pawns you
could maybe run into something like
bishop to d6
attacking the rook then you might see
bishop to c5 with a double attack on the
knight
the knight will not be able to move
because there's a uh will be a double
attack on the f2 pawn so
yeah although it's playable white is
better maybe just uh a bit too risky
so instead after d captures on e5 we
have knight to c6 right away
and now uh as the e7 bishop is under
attack so just
bishop the c5 uh getting that uh
bishop out of the way uh and now comes
uh
well queen to e2 uh you could also
capture this but after captures and
captures then white
just achieved what white wanted he has a
nice passport here on c6
and you don't have all that much to show
for so instead like i said after knight
c6 with bishop to c5 with a double
attack
not on that pawn but on this one and now
queen to e2 under defense it and then
now
rook f2 e8 so here uh white is still up
upon but black is playing very very
active chess and the
white will still have to white was still
have to prove that
uh that this position can be won so here
we have knight captures on e5 and this
is a
well a very interesting idea uh problem
is
if you play something like b4 it makes
kind of makes sense because you want to
get rid of this bishop here
then bishop d4 just wins the game for
black as
the knight is under attack you can't
move it because then your bishop
captures rook happens
and of course if you play something like
queen to d3 to defend it
well then just bishop captures queen
captures and e4 and that's it
uh the bishop now uh has to move and
after the bishop moves knight captures
on the e5
we remove the defender of the knight on
c6 while attacking the queen and now
well
uh white's position just falls apart so
it's a very very tricky position so here
knight captures an e5 this is what anand
decides to play
and now comes uh well now comes
rook captures an e5 uh it's a it's a
very
interesting idea to give up this knight
like this as then well the bishop will
capture on f2
but i guess anan just didn't want to
play it safe he could like bring the
queen back just queen to f1 queen to d2
and
get the queen away from this uh nasty e
file but he decided to play actively
knight captures on e5
rook out for on e5 so he wins the
exchange but he will lose the f2 pawn
and then black can win the exchange back
so queen captures on e5
bishop captures on f2 with check and now
the problem is
well a little bit of a problem the king
has to go to f1 if you go to h1
then you run into rook to e8 and now
after the queen moves
it's just game over for white so here
you would have to give up the queen
but you don't really have compensation
for that so instead after bishop
captures an f2 we have
king to f1 uh you have to play this
otherwise you're lost and now
uh black just regains material bishop
captures on e1
we have queen capture sonny one and now
b4
so playing in really great style and
black is playing this game incredible
incredibly well uh uh
uh ever since that move won where he
gave up a pawn for
uh i'm not gonna say no reason because
there's always a reason but
uh he just gave up upon on move one
uh to to to the former world champion uh
so here b4
uh opening up some lines for the for the
black queen we have a
captures queen captures now also putting
pressure on the b2 pawn
and rook to a2 this is how anand defends
but now bishop to b5 with
check and now the problem is uh you
cannot uh
you cannot capture this bishop because
if the bishop is captured then just
queen to c4 and
well you win the rook here on a2 so
instead after bishop to b5 check we have
the quick knight
back to e2 uh now blocking this and
offering a trade of queens
uh and now comes queen back to d6
uh so what do you play here the queen
wants to capture on h2 and then
white's pretty much done for so you have
to you have to prevent this we have
kinked the g1
but now uh well you have other problems
and that's
rook captures on c2 and now there's a
double attack on the knight on e2 so
what do you play here uh
knight to c3 but now comes bishop to d7
now the bishop wants to come to g4
uh trade off uh well either by capturing
an f3 or you want white to capture on g4
and then you will have a lot of pressure
here
so here we have queen to e3 and now
comes bishop to g4 as planned we have
bishop capture sanji for
knight captures and now uh this simply
does not work for
for uh anand uh because here we have
queen to e8
check king to h7 and now queen to e for
check
here anand nicely connects this check
with an attack on the knight
and on the rook here problem is after g6
you do not have a good move
uh because capturing on c2 just loses
queen captures an h2 checking f1 and now
knight the e3 check picks up the queen
on c2
so that most uh definitely was not a
free rook so after
g6 we have queen to g4 this seems to be
working but
there is a problem here as there is one
move that wins the game for
for nikhil uh so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find
this uh well uh maneuver that takes down
the former world champion vishwanathan
on and
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
either of the two checks queen to c5 or
queen to b6 uh as uh if you found this
that means white is lost because here
after queen to c5 check which was played
in the game
you can't go king to f1 because this is
just checkmate you have to play king to
h1
and now comes the fun part and that is
rook to c1 with
check we have knight to d1 and now
another
beautiful move queen captures on d5
attacking the knight with
a double attack but also attacking the
rook here and here it was in this
position on move 34
that vishwanathan anand resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
but that is not all there is to this uh
to this
ending of the game uh problem is nikhil
had only 13 seconds on the clock
in this position and anand had almost 10
minutes nine minutes and
some seconds i don't know the exact
amount and if he wanted to win this he
could have just played some like h3 he
could have played
like h3 give up material let's say if
queen captures here
then we don't care we just play king h2
next we're gonna bring the knight back
into the game
and he could easily flag his opponent
with who only had nine seconds on the
clock
but uh as our uh friend who suggested
this game captain agrawal says
uh vichy sir showed the spirit of a true
legend and resigned the game when he
could have flagged his opponent so
that's uh that's the kind of a
person on this he did not want to win
the game uh his opponent outplayed him
and he wanted to to congratulate him
in proper manner so really uh an
incredible game
and when i fir when i first received
this suggestion
i thought okay i'm playing in
celebrities it's just going to be you
know
swift victories for for him on all
boards and
especially when i saw move one in this
game after knight to f3
e5 i was like what then i checked the
database that it's called the ross
opening never heard of it
uh i i tried checking why the ros
opening i i couldn't find it so like i
said please
do uh do shed some light on this if you
if you have
you know vast knowledge in the comment
section so we can all
improve it uh but yeah incredible stuff
incredible how he was able to play such
a brilliant game
after this initial pawn sacrifice uh he
he just played incredibly
active chess like like morphy would and
he you know
all of a sudden he had a an equal game
and then all of a sudden he had uh
he had a winning position so really just
incredible stuff okay and
of course he's playing a simultaneous
exhibition he's playing against multiple
opponents and uh
well it's uh even with all that
it's still amazing that he was able to
play such a game such such an incredibly
strong
game with all the moves being well
incredibly strong
so um it's not it's not uh odd
because there are people who you know
quit chess when they were
very young and um well just started
doing something else and they became
incredibly successful in that uh much
like the
the the ceo of deepmind for example demi
sazabis also was an incredible chess
player then just you know had to drop
chest to to be able to achieve
all the other stuff uh this could be
could be the case here because
he topped at the rating of 2050 i
believe
um so who knows who knows how strong he
was actually
and you know if he still kept improving
and playing secretly but
all in all it's this was an incredibly
impressive uh
showing uh by by nicole come out here
india's uh
you know youngest billionaire so that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it thank
you for suggesting it and also
uh learning about the ross opening i
imagine it will become very very popular
in online plays
it really gives active play for black i
would like to thank
happy birthday s paul avijid banerjee
tsang console of
western carpet cleaning in corporate and
izaka garuda for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of all the
tournaments that we are following
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the uh
world of chess
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday